have a look at my working how did I use
that angle what did I put it into can
you recognize his life do you recognize
that this is a cosine rule right you can
know because cosine this is C squared
equals a squared plus B squared minus 2a
b cos C okay now I don't like this
popular down parlor reason why is
because there's already an A and a B and
a C in the question and I don't want to
confuse myself so I've looked at the
formula sheet I have noticed okay which
side is relevant relevant here to weak
angle and so I've written down that line
how did that look this is that are we
okay after this line or job in a purse
Plato that's right okay so yeah question
you're all excited all for instance
according to that diagram understanding
how the sugar so the question was if my
diagram up here is wrong and I do
subsequent things
offer the base of that diagram well I
still get some marks basically um the
short answer is is depend and it's a
pencil of how a drastically wrong your
diagram for example if I draw if I draw
a really ridiculous diagram suppose like
you know I don't know like the order of
the things is wrong or I'm off like
going in a different direction or
something like that sometimes you can
render yourself unable to solve the
question so the stuff down here it stops
making sense could you have angles that
are negative and it is drawn your work
is just a bit of advancement once though
it's confusing right if you did it
inside is a good chance you could
progress but then what you've done is
made the question easier so you wouldn't
be able to get for works cuz you see I
have to work to find out what that angle
was but you're just like I know the
angles so it depends I'm happier working
sure working individually
so I've got the angle inside the
triangle the three and the eight are the
sides that are around that are about the
angle so that's what gives me a see I've
just sort of crunched from my calculator
okay how many people got AC ends up
straight okay thank you hands down not
heaps of us so I guess this is a point
where you know you get no help from the
questions in terms of what information
is relevant how do I start to step
through this and work out what direction
I need to go in if you're working out a
leg my advice to you is you've got to
know some other legs in there and
they've given them to you and you'll
need some bagels the trickiest piler
here which was okay once you have that
9.7 it doesn't let up this is an HSC
type question so don't expect it to be
easy
what is the berry of sea froth a okay
before you look at my working come back
to the diagram don't look at it because
this is the important part first do you
see what I've got up there a couple in
the top left-hand corner you see that
that's where I've written berry or see
from a I want to know where this angle
is that I'm calculating do you agree
that that's the very old see from a do
you see I'm measuring from up there and
I'm 20 down here okay once I know what
I'm working out what's this angle here
this one that I'm coloring in orange
that's 90 degrees because it's a
comforts right he walks you see ya so in
order to get the berry in the whole
purple angle I just need to add on this
little bit in between that okay so then
that becomes my mission all right that's
the start the angle I'm after so if I
know all the sides of this triangle
that's nine point seven remember what
information can I use to work out the
tiny little angle coil I can use cosine
rule I could use sine rule but I try to
avoid side why is that remember
because it could be a to I mean on on
this diagram obviously it's not but I
sort of always default to cosine rule
because it will always give me the right
answer and I never need to water okay
here I've got one two three sides so
there's no reason not to
okay that's what this working looks like
I will put up this so that you can see
what I'm doing but the important thing
is what I then do with this angle you
see I get the sides inside the triangle
53
I felt the bearing but that is not the
bearing what am I done
look at my final line this line kion
yeah that's very good I saw the actual
bearing I'm after is 90 Plus this angle
so that's why I added on and that's what
do you see disparity okay how you
traveling so far yes and let me have a
look so let me just remind myself on the
formula sheet you can see that the
cosine rule is written twice and since
this orbit and the flesh log is provided
a folded Society and the second one is
providing the four bits for angle so you
really can use models and that's why
we're doing it okay so you can see
inside the triangle let me zoom out a
little bit I found at that tiny angle up
they ready to get up this tiny England
why okay in the corner is 63 so my
diagram is got pieces of scale but some
battle I added 90 to get the berries
there is 143
okay then actually shot the final
question it is quite hard is this like I
said if you've got a berries question
sorry got a trick question
anyway
beginning of the paper you get one of
these and it'd be like cool okay
identify for me last substitute and
you're done if you get a tree question
towards the ends of the paper it's going
to be one of these okay so don't write
here this down just watch with me
because all the data and then also can
work here so you can copy everything the
question says very of a form C so this
is the reverse of what the previous
question which passage yeah so why go it
to the diagram and you see me put it in
here right this is the bearing of a haze
over there Ron
see some measure to see right so I start
from North like I always do and I spin
all the way around and give it this wind
of reflex angles are perfect quarters
more than 180 degrees more than 270
degrees actually is all the way around
so that's all I go try and fun okay now
how are you doing we're going to do it I
know if I went all the way around
I get 360 right so if I just sort of
panel back a little bit that'll tell me
what the Barry I just have to work out
how far back I have to go
you see how they these two angles hiding
in here it can I can find out what these
are then I just need to subtract them
from 360 that'll get me there you with
me so far a lot of jokes are going up so
we revise all the ways to execute but I
want to go all the way I don't want to
come to here okay I'm going to work out
what's missing from the whole treatise
okay
look back
remember has to be cleaning when we
choose diagram exhibition remember what
that was what pieces made internally now
the bearing of same from baby right I
spun it on the solid wall okay so I put
a North and Nokia North wires are always
going to be parallel right so therefore
almost between these two parallel lines
adds up these two here which are
actually Co interior and I look Co
interior so let me help you see a little
bit on a cheap yeah there we go there we
go okay
can you see it there you did she are all
the way down yeah
you're not cold Sheree is like that see
I will then see it's just really squash
the robot on its own okay so in ER these
two angles are stuff in it for again
supplementary very good so that's why
I'm doing it's getting lately after the
middle that's why I did this do you see
what I'm doing
that's 155 what's the other part that
makes up 180 and the answer is 25 does
that matter
look like 25 yeah it's like a little
angle right so I'll call that 25 I've
got this how we'll work out this this
guy here okay now do you remember when I
worked out this angle over here I had to
do the cosine rule I said one two three
side I have to sweat all the way through
it and I got the same really any awkward
weight I've got that angle and I've got
the chain rule cuz I just like that
so which one this was that was the
previous question so how do I get this
bearing you have models so cuz they're
all in here okay I'll show you the
working gentle eyes but my point is I
know what the angle is
all right so I subtract this morning
this Plus this Plus this in what a she
can fly what that angle is
then it is my working okay you see what
I'm doing good this is inside the
triangle okay so I can't stick the
triangle on that H so but you've got it
in front of you right so ATC PhD and VCA
they're the angles are all inside and
they all add up to 180
okay I worked out these two angles in
the previous questions like that's why
this is part a cutter why don't they say
sorry hundred um you can be an earlier
part of the question I worked at the
dating so I can use them this is the one
that I don't know probably when you do
the subtraction is 12 degrees middle
again my diamonds are onyx 1200
calculated I'm going to be encrypted
I've been doing the decoration but then
remember what I was going to do with
that angle this is hot you were at the
very end
yeah so I found these at 25 this is 12
per 360 takeaway 25 and 12 is 300 and I
talked member 326